all of this was mere prelude to the
greatest of revolutionary cosplayers
so fresh so unbelievably face the face
of freshness and the fresh of facemasks
aoc showed up to the mecala
now nothing says woman of the people
like showing up to a gala where the
average ticket cost thirty thousand
dollars
now i assume she didn't pay for that i
assume that she was gifted the ticket by
somebody in the management at the met
gala
she wore a white dress
from a
i i actually was wondering who the maker
of the dress was
apparently the maker of the dress is
some famous shoe designer
i guess they don't even sell dresses
normally so they made it special for her
and she was wearing a special white
dress with a slogan on the back of it
reading tax the rich
tax
the rich
at the met gala
surrounded
by all of the rich people including aoc
who makes 174 thousand dollars a year
not being a barmaid but being a a person
who is in congress mouthing off on
instagram
she is not a member of the lower classes
in the united states gang neither is
bernie sanders bernie sanders is a
millionaire who owns three homes
aoc is not a member of the blue collar
working class any longer
okay so aoc shows up to the met gala to
hobnob with the rich and famous now
notice again this is cosplaying the
revolution she isn't outside yelling at
the people going into the met gala that
they need to be taxed more she's not
outside telling them that they should be
giving all of the money not to the
metropolitan museum of fashion but to
actual poor people
because let me tell you something if you
donate to the metropolitan museum of art
that money ain't going to the poor okay
instead the idea here is that she is
she's a heroine it's iconic according to
reporters for rolling stone iconic
uh
incredible
she is uh so here she is wearing this
dress that says tax the rich
and we're all supposed to swoon because
again she's not actually doing anything
revolutionary she's going to a bunch of
people who agree with her about taxing
the rich at least when they're at events
like this and then they go home and they
say to their accountant so where do i
stash my cash so i don't get taxed
that's how it actually works in
hollywood we have a bunch of hollywood
higher ups i'm happy to pay as m i'm
happy to pay the highest taxes at all
the land and then they call up
they call it burma the accountant
they're like okay
figure out where to stash cayman islands
would that work for you how do i avoid
paying what's the minimum i can pay i
notice a lot of these people are not big
on actually the giving of the charity or
the signing of a larger checks to the
federal government i've noticed
but uh aoc decides to show up and she's
going to shame them and they all
look deeply ashamed right they all look
as though they have been just slapped in
the face with a wet fish or
alternatively they know
that she's just part of the game
because again robespierre didn't show up
at verse i
wearing hulo that said
kill the monarchs
he just killed the monarchs
if you're going to be a revolutionary
you got to be a revolutionary you don't
get to hobnob with the let them eat cake
crowd which is what she is doing
and there's still a lot of people in
this country who are suffering who can't
go back to work in new york city you
can't go back to work in a lot of places
because of all the vaccine requirements
aoc's district is one of the less
wealthy districts in new york
and here she is taking that joe manchin
who's really bad joel mentioned
plutocrat joe manchin i didn't see him
at the met gala
i didn't see this piece of work in the
miguel
there she was the mech ally hobnobbing
with all of her fashionable friends
standing up to the patriarchy standing
up to capitalism with all of these
beneficiaries of capitalism who are
dancing them with the mask of the red
death at the ball that protects them
from from being part of the rest of the
pandemic
it's uh it is galling to say the least
for sure now
i guess the dresses designer was aurora
james and she went with her dress
designer
and she discussed what it means to be
working class women of color at the met
yes yes wow it's like cinderella going
to the ball
yeah you well there there was aoc she
was sitting in her kitchen
doing an instagram post about how to
make a smoothie and she looked over into
the fire and she just began sifting
through the ashes for a for a potato a
crumb to eat
and that's when they began calling her
ao cinderella
and ao cinderella then had billy porter
arrive as the fairy godmother
and grant her her wish which was to go
to the ball with all of the special
people
wearing a dress that said on the back
tax
the rich
wow
and then she turned back into a pumpkin
she had to go back to washington dc and
hang out with all the other pumpkins
so here she was blue collar aoc
explaining her own heroism ah not all
heroes wear capes some wear two thousand
dollar dresses designed by aurora james
here here she is
when aurora and i were first kind of
partnered
uh we really started having a
conversation about what it means to be
working class women of color at the met
and oh my god
you know we can't just
play along but we need to break the
fourth wall and challenge some of the
institutions and
and
you know while the met is known for its
spectacle we should have a conversation
about it
well well they're known about the
spectacle we should have a conversation
about it you know what the conversation
is that you're a hypocrite that's the
conversation we're standing outside with
a sign saying give all the money to the
poor you're inside having ha after
having been gifted a given a seat by the
mat and partnered with aurora james who
apparently is the creative director and
founder of a luxury accessories brand
called brother of ellie's which by the
way i should know brother vellis i'm
just going to read you some of the
prices from their their website okay the
brother velli's products
um i'm gonna just look at their at their
their shoes right now
okay they have a tris sandal for 285
dollars
they have socks for 35 bucks a pair
which seems kind of expensive for socks
i will note
she has shoes called the beirut slide
for 615 dollars but aurora these are
working class women of color fighting
back against capitalism the patriarchy
why does any of this matter why does
that gala matter why does aoc and all
this why is this important the reason
it's important is because the same
people who call for tearing down the
systems are the beneficiaries of the
system
if you're going to do something like the
met gala it should be a celebration of
capitalism because frankly that's what
makes all of this possible it should be
a celebration of free markets and
competition and creativity and
entrepreneurship which is really what is
happening at the met gala instead it's a
bunch of
masturbatory idiots talking about how
terrible are the systems under which we
live while simultaneously living the
highest on the hog it is possible to
live and making mockeries of themselves
in the process
and you know what good because it shows
what idiots they are it shows that for
them
the political stance it's like a purse
it's just an accessory
that's all okay the political stance is
not some sort of deeply rooted belief
system for a lot of these folks it is
not about what they believe in their
heart of hearts because they are willing
to shed that in order to go to a
cocktail party with all the famous folks
what it is really about more than
anything
all of the radical left's most ardent
proposals are aoc's dress they are all
expensive dresses
built on the back of an incredibly
prosperous system saying tax the rich
it's all signaling
all it is is i'm a good person because
like i'd be a bad aoc would be a bad
person if she'd just gone to the met
gala and didn't say tax the rich on the
back but it did say tax the rich on the
back so now she's a good person now
she's virtuous
carol devine wearing a stupid bib that
probably cost a couple thousand dollars
wearing say if it hadn't said anything
we would just think look at these
decadent idiot celebrities
but
but she had embroider on it peg the
patriarchy and that means that she is a
morally praiseworthy person
megan rapino would just be a whiny
soccer player
playing a sport that very few people
watch except once every four years when
the media decide it's important
and then whining about a salary contract
that she herself signed that's all she
would be except for the fact that she
walks around talking about how
victimized she is in american society
and how the institutions are bad
the greatest grift in america is living
on the back of the greatest system ever
put to paper and then talking about what
a victim you are while living high on
that system it is the most amazing grift
i've ever seen and so many of our
politicians do it and this is joe biden
who has never taken a private sector
paycheck hey joe biden has never run a
business joe biden has never done
anything worthwhile is in the man was
elected to the senate of the united
states when he was 29 years old
he is a congressional welfare case
and here he is talking about the evils
of the system that have made him worth
millions and millions of dollars
hey and by the way that system the
political patronage system that made
millions and millions of dollars because
that's why he's rich see there's a
difference between politicians who are
rich before and then go into politics
and people who are not rich and then
became rich because they were
politicians like joe biden which is kind
of despicable
the
the amazing spectacle in the united
states of people
who
benefit from the system ripping the
system for pay and fun
is just it's an amazing amazing thing to
watch and you should always keep that in
mind because that's what they're doing
because what does that really amount to
in the end what it amounts to is they
are better than you they are more
morally praise worthy than you you see
aoc is more morally praiseworthy than
you
are just a restauranteur you're just
somebody who owns a small restaurant in
rural indiana
and you know you don't think the
institutions should be torn down you
don't have the vision you're not like
uber max kennedy you don't see the deep
roots of evil in the system well you
know getting 10 million checks from from
jack dorsey over at twitter
and and running a center for anti-racism
research that to date has produced zero
research at boston university right
you're just a person who runs a business
and tries to make sure that your
employees have money to take home and
you try to put food on the table for
your kids and maybe you try to service
your customers
but you don't stand up against the
institutions which means that you're bad
and you're stupid
these people they're special they're
elite they are better than you because
they have not only succeeded in the
system they recognize the evils of the
system
and this makes them superior to you
and what does that mean
what that really means is that we are
just supposed to ignore everything they
actually do on the ground in favor of
the proposition that you are bad and you
are you are morally blameworthy
your life does not matter your your
prospects do not matter your hopes and
your dreams do not matter because you
are not part of the cosplaying
revolutionary brigade
because these folks are like a dog if
they actually caught the car they
wouldn't know what to do with it
yeah really if these are if tom ford and
timothy chalamet and aoc if they ever
caught the car and they instituted
the socialist revolution that they
apparently so ardently seek
they might be quite unhappy with the
results the most ardent communists in
the united states have never lived under
communism and the most ardent
capitalists in the united states have
there is a reason for that there's a
reason that cuban expatriates come to
the united states and they understand
the evils of communism while all the
communists in the united states were
born in the united states and went to
our top universities
and and again it comes down to the way
that they are going to to
re and reinstill reinforce
their own sense of moral superiority is
to crap on you
right and it comes out in everything
they do it really does
how's this for a title ben shapiro show
subscriber destroys like button with
clicks and logic i'd watch that make it
happen gang